[Music]
i think i could build it to sell it
which what i want to know from your
perspective is that even a good plan
building to sell so part of me is like
yes it's clear path to make money
another part is like it's kind of lame
though
yeah well i think where you're at now
let's take three three options
build to sell
that which is basically optimizing for
like oh is there a sort of like a flip
is there a
is there a buyer on the other side of a
business like this
another one is build to win which is
basically like
um
for example when i talk to these bankers
what i'm trying to figure out is
what which of these businesses is like
not a special snowflake where it's like
oh
that's actually like a rinse and
repeatable model like i didn't like
that founder didn't like catch lightning
in a bottle at the perfect time and it's
their perfect background and they got
really lucky about this one thing it's
like oh those i don't want to emulate i
want to emulate the one where it's like
hey i think somebody could start that
same business today and do equally well
or do do just as well in this one
adjacent space and like you don't need
to be a genius with that and so that's
the second part of it which is like
build to win it's like optimizing for
something that's gonna work
and then there's the last one which is
sort of like
you know build for fun or build for
mission which is like
go for something that like you something
you would never want to sell
that you're willing to do even if it's
low likelihood of success i think we all
know the answer is to do that bucket
right like i think
the question is like
how many how much security do you need
before you go do the thing you know you
should do well or it could be a
combination of all three uh like it
could be like you enjoy winning or you
enjoy this space and you want to make it
successful but there's a great clip from
you and uh what's uh free what's what's
uh all in
david freeburg there's a great clip that
i shared that you and him had where he
basically said that founders
always sell themselves short and they go
for these small ideas because because
they think it's more reasonable but when
doing that they kind of screwed
themselves because it's actually easier
sometimes to do much of grander bigger
ideas because that attracts the crazy
types of people who you want to work
with um you can interact competitive
because nobody else no not every joe is
going to try to you know do it like you
know going and trying to you know start
a
railroad business or whatever versus an
fba business it's like well they're both
going to take all your time so that's
equal
money well you're going to have to go
raise money from investors one will let
you just raise you're still going to get
the money you need from investors
just one you maybe raise more at a
higher valuation and the other one
you'll raise less at a lower evaluation
right like but did you agree do you
agree with him
i i do agree with him and i've thought
this for a very long time i remember uh
back in the day did you ever hear about
this thing called the unreasonable
institute i don't even think this is
around anymore that's a great name it's
sort of like the same guys who did
summit it's not it's not actually the
same guys but it's the same it was like
the same idea it was like right the
unreasonable institute was basically
this like it was based on this one word
unreasonable in the way that the hustle
is built on this one word hustle and uh
trans is built on one word trends and so
the unreason was it was exactly that it
was like
it's going to take unreasonable people
to do unreasonable things for the world
to move forward and it was like very
inspiring and then they met with all a
bunch of you know a bunch of people who
did that the sort of elon musk types who
went and did unreasonable things and
then you start to look at it and you're
like
you know all things equal
um
you know i guess like your inputs are
sort of the same it's just your time and
energy and then like the outputs can be
very very different because
the inputs aren't the same because it is
possible to build something pretty cool
and not work that hard
but it's kind of impossible to build
something huge and not work very hard
all right who do we know and let's do
real examples i'm not saying it's not
true but who do we know that's building
successful awesome businesses without
working too hard
well
how about suli i actually don't know
what's his schedule does he grind
constantly
he works hard yes he works hard
so then no one you don't we don't know
anyone but
you and me like maybe i'll give you one
nuance on it he got there faster than
the normal person so it looked like it
came easier but that's just because he
was better it wasn't because he worked
like he he wasn't putting in a tenth of
the hours he was putting in the same
number of hours and getting there 10
times faster which is i just think that
like there's a world where you have
business a and it doesn't grow nearly as
fast and you're working 40 hours a week
and then you have business b that's
growing significantly faster and you
have to work 100 hours a week like that
that is a reality yes that's true that's
what i'm talking about i'm not talking
about like very little i'm talking about
normal versus not normal there's also
things like this podcast or like people
who have like newsletters or blogs or
something like that where it's like or
they teach a course it's like you know
like let's take your buddy neville right
so
neville i don't think you and me
well because i'm doing multiple things
right so it's like on each one i'm not
putting in as much time but like overall
i'm working harder and if i didn't do
those other things
that one thing would just expand in time
i would just do more i would say how
often are you working now a day
normal work hours
uh not normal hours but
i work like a
the equivalent of eight hours a day got
it just not all to it not not all
continuously all right but back to what
was the original point so my my point
was like uh is it
is this really true that you can kind of
like chill and win
and like no i didn't mean
to say
i mean chill less or sorry chill more
work less
okay so then bro if you agree with
friedberg which i think i do
why are you
not going after like one big grand thing
like i started a newsletter that's not
exactly like you know that's not like
world changing entirely it's neat but i
would i would put it on a six out of ten
in terms of like
maybe a five in terms of like big ideas
right
yeah i i agree with you the
reason why is because to me it's not a
bigness contest
it's a do i have a clear picture of what
i want like my life to be
and then can i like do i have a crystal
clear picture and then can i make that
happen
and it's like knowing what i want and
then getting what i want and so what i
wanted was not to work the hundred hours
right even though i even though i agree
like
that's cool it's fun and if i did do it
i do think there's all these extra
benefits you'd get amazing talent to
come join you you'd make a bunch of
money you'd uh have a bunch of fun like
there's there's great benefits if i did
the big one the the big big big one but
i decided that like what i wanted
yeah yeah what i wanted more was more
like the
40 hour
a week
but hours spent on doing these types of
things like i love teaching teaching's
not the most
it's not the most like
world-changing unreasonable institute
style you know like let's go land a
rocket on mars type of idea but i have
the most fun doing it so i'm just
optimizing for like a different thing
rather than bigness i'm optimizing for
like you know my own enjoyment and so
that's why i'm not going after that so i
need things that are sufficiently
interesting
so that i'm interested and big enough so
i don't feel like i'm wasting my time
but like
it's not maximally big
[Music]
you